hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the wine
oh it's just white night what is that
nothing screw i don't feel [ __ ] lady i
feel absolute terror into my deepest
bones I'm getting out of here screw you
that doctor is not here to help me I can
tell I do not trust her at all Hey look
who's painting who's this hey don't tell
me to shush
it's hot too hot my body can't handle it
it's bright too bright Maya
my eyes went blind it's unbearable to
hear those screams hell of a I'm
covering my ears in hope I'll go deaf
that wasn't the direction I wanted to
take that no I wanted to take it in
another direction
what am i doing what am i doing
stop that stop that oh stop it
no stop it okay ha ha oh my fangirls
just went insane yeah okay still can't
see a need flashlights why I don't have
flashlights alright I recorded this in
sequential so if you guys in the last
steps were like I'm like fudge guess I'm
doing this on hardmode 1878 the st.
State lunatic Hospital at Denver was
erected under the supervision of
prominent Boston architect annual Jay
Bradley and in an extremely rural
out-of-the-way location the immediate
crisis which precipitated the building
of a mental hospital north of Boston was
the early in the early South Boston
building I learned of crazy there all
right I'm not really interested
there's too much today Denver State
Hospital is a forgotten and desolate
place yeah I'm crazy nutso and I'm not
even supposed to be here this doctor
does not want to help me locked locked
fu alright gotta fight
did I miss a flashlight somewhere
because I swear oh I swear if I did I'm
gonna be so pissed cuz I can't see any
ten I cannot see any ten at all and if I
have to go through this game with no
flashlight I'm gonna lose my mind why
was it so easy to not pick it up did I
just miss it
ah ah bollocks I did didn't I
I did I did didn't I didn't I did didn't
I did do that
59 I did do dad okay I got a screwdriver
wait a minute
I have a crazy idea it's just so crazy
it might not work at all I can't even
find that where the projection Oh God
gosh darn it George Turner cannot see
there it is okay I'm gonna screw you oh
wait I got a oh oh my being a little too
creepy no I'm not okay so how do I get
into the patient's eyes the way a
patient's okay here we go
blood dropping from the ceiling I have
no idea that's a blessing
no dr. Patrick clearance is out of
control and I administered one dose of
sedative Clarence that's not up to me
but I think his condition is getting
worse
he started claim that someone named
Phillip was trying to get rid of him if
you pardon my curiosity just who is his
Phillip why is he thinking that he tries
to kill him for other patients welfare I
locked him to the observationally in
until further notice okay guy the way
stupid [ __ ] inanimate object that I'm
not gonna name
[Music]
damnit maybe I can cut to a powwow yeah
with my screwdriver I don't know what I
was trying to say there what maybe I can
break it fine get over here
stickles Oh finally good golly I've
waited so long for this moment
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no I just got
a sudden feeling of dread as I realized
that I'm now in the dark and I'm in the
dark this is not good I don't know where
where what door open up if there's one
open over there's one over there damn
dark Oh God
okay i'ma die I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die how about that oh oh
how am I die what freakin door I don't
even know which door open up AHA I see
just dead matter if I wait too much he
will catch me no no no no go into the
room you dick what sort of crazy
hospital am I in
oh no lights went off in here - no why
why why why
I don't like this I hate the Justine
music all of the Justine music is so
terrifying
the Justine music is like the worst ever
I think I could finally make it through
here oh nice in here after all there was
nothing scary there's nothing there's
nothing scary no get away from me man
get you I'll back off mama you don't
know who you're messing with my name is
markiplier and are you oh wait I could
turn that on a while ago I bet it
doesn't work now cuz all the lights are
off I'm gonna run out of batteries here
pretty soon okay whatever whatever
whatever was there a light switch in
here - no there was nothing in here I
don't know I don't know I'm out of here
I'm out of here screw that screw that
hey yo I just realized the screws were
too tight what am i a giant [ __ ] can I
unscrew some screws wasn't this wooden
door where am I going why am I so
confused always I'm always confused why
why is I am that why is IR that is why
is that RB the way I do gonna use like
aa hospital ha ha ha [ __ ] yeah I don't
take [ __ ] from nobody yeah anything up
there new anything down there probably
well if I'm gonna find out oh look this
is totally reminding me of cry fear the
bathroom scene felt ah fu if you so hard
maybe you two heard up the butt hope the
butt
hook the button up
oh but give me give me give me give me
give me give me give me give me give me
give me give me give me a baby okay okay
ah hello Oh
cyclical it looks like lunk know why did
I have to cut the power
why did I have to be that kind of a dick
huh oh hello I can barely hear you dude
what that why Oh pull it down during the
lights on what
as if screw you man
[Music]
what was that wait whoa whoa calm down
there I missed that
the code was in there somewhere okay
thank god this guy got it the last digit
of the password is half the second digit
second digit is equals the number the
washbasins in the restroom I think it
was six if I'm not mistaken so that's
the last digit of the password um that's
the last in the second digits but I
still need another digit did you did you
did you did you I need another digit I
need another digit do I need two more
actually I think it was six one two
three four six
yeah pounds right ha okay so that means
it's the second is six and then the last
one is three why did that take me so
long my brain is not working my brain is
not working in the face of adversity
hello hello
batteries hell yeah about damn time I
was just about to run out I swear man
505 that's number one five six blank
three five six three five six
mmm and then three what is the last one
oh five six two three five six two three
okay let's see five six two three I know
the password now where do I put it in I
don't remember all seeing like a panel
on I think I trust that closet 5 6 2 3 5
2 tree line
ah whoo you oh I can do that no I'm not
always 506 a to treat ah yeah Oh Super G
[Music]
no how about you're not any better
happened to me why is there no one but
me in this place why is that screw you
uh-huh who you not show your progress
what are you talking about yeah yeah
yeah I don't believe you why don't I
believe you stop saying that because I'm
crazy so
what happened to me you should know
you're a good person David
but there are bad things to me
I haven't done anything wrong yeah I I
don't I
why do you think you're seeing dead
bodies David how do you know I'm seeing
dead bodies
[Music]
deeply you bury it but there is a bright
side that's why there are things
attacking me
they never noticed me I got away with it
clean no one knows how stupid I was
acting okay
oh no oh no oh no they dropped me right
back they keep dropping me right back
where I was but I guess that's the
intention which means that the monsters
are nearby and the damn sheep wailing
going on in the background is gonna
continue hey where's my batteries hell's
to the yeah and he's a computer yeah I
haven't been able to use a computer
since penumbra what was that what was
that what was that all right I'm all out
of time thank you all so much for
watching click the annotations for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]